are you hot for
any Lisa does he have more of a
basketball b or a football B he doesn't
play
sports my tenda is grave I talk to him I
wish I was with
you that's really weird
[Music]
Lisa
you hear that I'm sure it's the girl
next door she's very
odd your
hand I can't believe you're here do you
like music I have the Cure oh not that
kind of cure they can't make you better
I mean they can but like emotionally no
don't cry your tears to smell so
bad send it back you need a friend no I
love it it's not really my
style when you're in doubt L looks good
she could probably even do pageants if
she had
Congeniality your daughter has a little
psycho I open my glorious home to an
ungrateful
little tell
I want to help you but Taffy says it's a
waste of time to try and fix a Bo it's
better just accept a guy's faults that's
so
cute I have an idea there are bad people
out there come on Lisa it'll feel
good that hand was going to do terrible
things I'm sorry but I just
thinking you are being admitted
impatient look
down I could get the clink for life or
the electric chair but I don't want to
die a
virgin you know anything about The
Disappearance of the
student I'm not making any more
comments you can talk to my lawyer
really hope this goth phase in soon you
need a
friend